we are now deep into the holiday season
approaching the end of the year so it's
time to come out and think a little bit
about giving some meaningful gifts to
people there's many types of gifts that
can stand in back and forth with secret
Santa and gift exchanges people making
cookies all sorts of other gifts that go
back and forth but the one gift that so
many people forget about is the gift of
holiday dickory
why shouldn't you being like the Grinch
or go beyond the Grinch and Grinch It Up
by telling people that they've got the
holidays wrong when they come and wish
you Merry Christmas or something like
that then switch it on them and say
don't say merry Christmas say happy
holidays and then if they say happy
holidays pick any one of the holidays
and say oh you're trying to leave that
one out we should be saying happy
Hanukkah we should be wishing people a
merry Kwanzaa we should be picking
whatever is going to be outside of the
sphere of what it is that these other
people have in mind and thereby we can
bring something new to the table there's
enough holiday cheer there's enough
upbeat it's time to be a Debbie Downer
and introduce some tension some conflict
some anxiety into the holidays there's
probably already enough with people
blowing lots of money and wondering
where this is going to come from out of
their accounts or out of their income
and whether people are going to like the
gifts or not and how they're going to
get on with their relatives or their
colleagues or co-workers but can we add
a little bit more by getting upset and
getting into everybody's faces about the
wrong holiday messages
the possibilities for this are
practically infinite you're going to
have people wishing you all sorts of
things to your face and perhaps in
things like text but you can go on to
social media an entire world exists out
there in which you can jump onto a
conversation thread and remind everyone
that they're missing something or they
offended somebody or they could
potentially step on somebody's holiday
toes so why not be a jerk why not engage
in some dickery about that if they say
Merry Christmas then remind them that
it's also holidays for people who
celebrate Hanukkah or Kwanzaa or the
winter solstice
or pick whatever you want we've got the
new year coming up and that brings all
sorts of interesting quandries as well
how should we celebrate the new year
with drinking a debauchery with a kiss
at midnight or with coming at home
everybody's choices can easily be
condemned and criticized can't they I
mean you know we can also introduce the
holidays that are kind of new on the
scene Festivus for the rest of us the
inclusive holiday for all of those who
got left out Airing of Grievances and we
don't have to just do that Festivus we
can do without any time of the year but
especially when people are wishing us
happy holidays or mentioning any other
holiday we also have a couple others
National whiners day coming up you can
[ __ ] and moan about your Christmas
presents or the presents that you didn't
get or the ungratitude of people who are
not happy with whatever they got in the
secret santa exchange at work or you
know anywhere else right we can go on
and on and then of course we do have the
Festival of enormous changes at the last
minute to help us get ready for making a
whole bunch of crazy New Year's
resolutions that there's no possibility
that we can keep so remember as we now
headed in our full full length into the
holidays that it's up to you to make a
difference in other people's lives it's
up to you to give them the gift of
holiday dickory